[Music]
[Applause]
the 49ers insider for nbc sports bay
area will have better answers than i do
matt mayoko who's in his 26th year
covering the 49ers
matt thanks for joining us why are they
playing this game tonight
well because it's the nfl and the nfl
can do whatever the heck it wants and
they want to play football on a thursday
night hey uh
dan some late breaking news here uh my
colleague at nbc sports bay area
jennifer lee chan reports that there
were no
positive test results from the 49ers and
even the player who tested positive
yesterday kendrick bourne
tested negative so uh
those players won't be available to play
in tonight's game had it been a sunday
game they would be able to play
but that might give you a little
indication there too is that
you know they don't at least at this
point believe that there's some
outbreak going on with the 49ers uh
have they been able to practice they had
a
uh practice win uh tuesday night and
then after the building was cleared
last night they had a very brief walk
through so it's it's a thursday
game and so generally teams don't do a
whole lot of practicing
uh before a thursday game but uh they
did their meetings on zoom
yesterday and then a very brief get
together for a walk through last night
we see this with teams that go to the
super bowl lose the super bowl there's a
super bowl hangover but
how do you explain what's happened to
the niners this year
i i tell you what you know speaking from
experience i've never
had a hangover anything like what the
49ers are experiencing
i mean we're talking and i don't know if
you can put it on the the super bowl i
think there might have been a little bit
of a mindset you know going into the
season of hey let's just get back to the
super bowl and win it this time which
isn't really
i don't think the mindset you want but
when you're talking about
you know 12 players on injured reserve
and those are
significant players two more will be
going on
jimmy garoppolo and george kittle you
have two players on the pup list
four players on the covet 19 list so
when you look at the team that's suiting
up tonight
theoretically suiting up tonight
compared to the team that played the
packers in the nfc championship game
it bears no resemblance so you can't
necessarily expect
you know a team without richard sherman
without nick bosa without
deforest buckner who was traded away
without garoppolo kittle without their
top three running backs i mean i could
go on and on and on
you can't expect a team like that uh
compared to what the team looked like
last year to just pick right up and
steamroll through the nfc so they're
four and four
right now which puts them in the race
but i just don't know
who they're going you know they're going
to be relying on nick mullins and
jamichael hasty tonight and ross dwelly
at tight end
a bunch of guys you've never heard of uh
so you definitely need a program tonight
even if you're a niners fan
yes at some point i will be posting like
a list on twitter of
numbers and players because i mean
myself included but
uh there will be a lot of fans tuning in
who have no idea who might be touching
the ball
and another added element of this not
one player from that nfc championship
game who touched the ball for the 49ers
on offense will be suiting up tonight
other than that thinner by the way that
includes the center
when garoppolo is good is he great
can he be great i think when he's good
he's good
you know and that's kind of the issue i
think with him is
is that good enough though man i you
know what
if you're talking about going forward
for next season with a cap that's going
down
with a salary expected to be you know
he'll be 25 million
next year you know i just i don't look
at him right now
as a player as a quarterback who enables
kyle shanahan to just say
oh this is great he does all the things
i need him to do
and more so we can put more on his plate
to to me
it's kind of i mean just look at the
playoffs last year where
you know he wasn't asked to throw and in
that nc championship game he only
dropped back eight times
so i i think there's a an element
of the 49ers offense of running the ball
running the ball running the ball
and that's a lot by uh necessity because
yeah i just don't know that he's the
kind of quarterback he just put it on
on his shoulders i mean dan frankly at
the end of the 2017 season
when he had been with the team for just
a couple weeks and he stepped into the
lineup and played some really good
football and the 49ers had a bad team
that year
they had only had one win up to that
point they ended up winning the final
five games of the season
that jimmy garoppolo is a heck of a lot
like the
jimmy garoppolo that we saw last year
and even with the healthy games this
year
my point being that with kyle shanahan
he would expect his quarterback to go
like matt ryan
you're like good one year and then great
the next and that
maturation that improvement we never saw
from jimmy garoppolo
if i said to kyle shanahan you can trade
jimmy garoppolo straight up for matt
ryan
i i think that deal's made yeah
and and i'd even go so far as to say
kirk cousins i mean
uh wow kyle likes kirk cousins you know
kyle
had his mindset on kirk cousins uh
getting him as a free agent for the 2018
season and then bill belichick basically
gift wrapped uh garoppolo
and i mean jimmy's jimmy's a good player
he had a good season last year
but he just he hasn't taken that next
step
and you know some of it you can you can
place on the injury issue this year
two different high ankle sprains but but
i just don't know that
that he functions in kyle shanahan's
offense the way shanahan wants him to
function
i know you're a pro football hall of
fame voter
if antonio brown did not come back and
play football
how would the the hall of fame selection
committee view antonio brown's career
that's a good question um you know we
certainly i would look at it based on
who he's up against
uh you know you look at there's so many
guys
out there um i wouldn't i wouldn't
consider him a slam dunk
but i don't know that you know we would
as a group well i should only speak for
myself i wouldn't look at any of the
the off the field stuff and the
craziness that's happened over the past
couple years
he's a heck of a player but you're not
supposed to factor that in
no no you're not
you could factor it in from the sense
that he left a lot of
football you know on his couch because
he didn't make himself available to play
because of off the field stuff
i think that that's an area a little bit
of a gray area there but
quitting on a team i mean they're like i
understand and you guys have a tough job
i get it
but you know like t.o michael irvin
you know when you do things off the
field that affects your team on the
field
then i have to account for that
yeah and and i think you could make that
same argument with antonio brown right
that he's done stuff that has affected
teams so
i mean it's it's down the road uh i
i don't necessarily like to look at guys
in and say oh he's a you know he's a
first ballot hall of famer there are a
couple guys who are
but remember now we can only elect five
modern era
candidates every year so unless you're
tom brady you know or aaron rodgers or
you
you know your name if jj want a hall of
famer today
i would think so yeah i would think so i
mean i can't guarantee he's a first
ballot hall of famer
um i i think i was a little bit
surprised that's a yeah a little bit
surprised to say jason taylor and brian
erlocker were first ballot hall of
famers
but you know they got in uh they they
were going to get in eventually i'm not
saying that they weren't hall of famers
but when you start looking at that i
think where it's it's changed in recent
years is that
uh there used to be this queue right
well this guy's waited long enough he's
a hall of famer he deserves to get in
and and now it's just like you know plug
him in
get him in there now what's the craziest
argument you ever heard
oh when you're in the room you know what
i
i don't know that i've heard anything
it's pretty it's pretty straightforward
it doesn't get heated oh yeah it gets
heated
dan my first year on i i made the case
for
tara owens and it got heated
it got heated to the point that some of
my friends were in that room were coming
up to me afterward and like
saying hey sorry about that so i'm like
i don't you can't take it personally but
oh no it
it gets heated but it gets it last year
i don't think i heat it at all
it's kind of what you're talking about
it's those kind of polarizing candidates
where people really take a stand one way
or the other but
through most of it you can kind of you
know last year i don't know that there
was
any negativity in that room it was just
that
hey you know this guy's great but we
like this guy better i mean
there was i don't recall anyone just
going after a candidate last year or
even
the last couple years so most of it is
is very positive because all the guys in
that room were there for a reason
julian edelman
that's a tough one i i don't know i i
think that that one
that one might take a while i just don't
know that he's had the
the uh you know the the career the
regular season career the numbers
i mean if you look at the postseason but
has somebody ever gone into the hall of
fame
and not been a pro bowl player yeah i
don't think so yeah
yeah would you rather have julian
edelman's career or
calvin johnson i don't know who made
more money
calvin johnson did you take that no yeah
mean i i think probably calvin johnson
and he's up
uh i believe this year he's he's a first
ballot
candidate yeah this year but he's a
tough one too because
you know when you get into like i i
thought patrick willis
had a strong case to at least be in the
top 15 in his first year
i mean basically every year he played in
the league he was a
he was an all-pro player he was a pro
bowl player he didn't even make it into
the top
15 his first year so you know
then you start talking about luke
keikley you know luke healey and
in patrick willis there's not a whole
lot to to separate those two
and i would put calvin johnson in that
same category where
for a short period of time very very
dominant and along those lines
tony beselly i mean tony biselli's
shorter career is probably even
than those guys but you're talking about
a premium position
left tackle those guys are hard to find
it seems like more guards are in than
tackles because guards can stay in that
position and play and be in the pro bowl
12 years
a left tackle those guys are are so
difficult to find that if you can get a
guy playing at a high high level for
four
five six years you really have to
consider him for the hall of fame
phillip rivers i i think so
yeah i think eventually again you know
can't say first ballot but
i would say that there are so many guys
and we could kick through
i was just thinking the other day about
all the tight ends that are out there
and in in you know guys who are in that
that queue right or guys who are going
to be coming through there but
it's the toughest position though when
you look at
as a voter the toughest position to
assess now with today's numbers
and who is a hall of famer and who's not
well i do think wide receiver
is getting more difficult i think that
the the most difficult
i think positions to assess are kind of
the grunt work positions
you know how do you how do you grade a
guard you know a center a left tackle a
right tackle
um how about the defensive tackles i
mean it's so much
part is put onto sacks if you're a
defensive lineman
well you can definitely be a hall of
fame player and not have a hundred sacks
and so those are the positions where you
can't
you can't compare apples to apples that
makes it difficult then when you start
comparing
different guys in different positions to
those grunt work guys who you don't have
a staff for that that's where it becomes
really difficult
yeah i figured running back because it
used to be you got to 10
000 yards and you became a hall of famer
now
you know we have these hybrids i i
thought fred taylor might be a hall of
famer i thought ricky waters deserved to
be in the hall of fame ricky waters was
sort of the forerunner to
what is today's running back now he was
great pass catcher
ran for you know tiki barber on the cusp
there as well
but i i don't know how to assess those
numbers or how
we'll assess those numbers at running
back in the uh in the coming years
yeah and of course you know i cover the
49ers so people here you know roger
craig
you know why isn't he in the hall of
fame you know he was he was a finalist
with the blue ribbon committee
last year as they kind of expanded the
hall of fame class
but i mean talking about a guy there
that that played fullback
played half back caught passes out of
the backfield and he was kind of the guy
that enabled
bill walsh to do everything he wanted
from that offense so yeah i know
it's a it's a it's very difficult um
and and i have my one vote and and
you throw it in there and you see what
comes out the other side
uh we appreciate you getting up and uh
sharing this information with us matt
have fun tonight
and uh we hope to have you on again
thank you very much all right dan i
appreciate it thank you
matt mayoko he's 49ers insider nbc
sports bay area